we all trained in big bear
right here in southern california
right yeah
in big bear
and it's funny because we would always
cross each other um like his posse and
my posse we would always cross each
other during like morning runs you know
and it was kind of like [ __ ] uh
what's that what's that movie where
they're like [ __ ] with knives and
[ __ ] like you know it's like west side
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
sport sport and paul
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg
[Music]
are you a gambler i am i i like gambling
i i hate the way i eat [ __ ] every day
we see you cheering on the sidelines not
chicago we're at home uh get in the
action this season with my bookie head
to mybookie.ag and bet on the nfl lock
of the season you could win big
go to mybookie.ag and use code omghi
that's oh my god hi to instantly receive
double your first deposit that's double
your funds to double your winnings at
mybookie.ag with code
omghi
oh my god hi i think it makes looking at
sports more fun when you're doing this
[Music]
and actually one of my
chefs
after i won the olympic games was one of
the guys that beat his ass down
it was [ __ ] hilarious man they would
have kicked this they would have killed
them right if they hadn't
the good guys the good guys got them it
would have been the bad guys it would
have been the guys from the bottle
they'd have killed them what do you mean
good guys got them yeah
it wasn't the hood rats it wasn't it
wasn't the gang members that got him so
you don't think a good guy
he tried he tried to steal this woman's
car most of them that activates every
latino over there
like from mexico they hit him in the
head the husband hit him in the head the
guy's tired he's been running at a
sprint over fences over the sound walls
for uh a couple of miles he's out of it
there was no and and they didn't beat
him you know they they they put him down
okay so this is his this is richard
ramirez morning so he he goes to arizona
go see his brother his brother won't see
him so he gets on the greyhound and
comes back now he's been gone with three
days three days he left on wednesday so
he gets in saturday morning he gets off
the greyhound bus right there in l.a and
he looks and a criminal really knows
what's going on you know so he looks
and he sees [ __ ] he's like you know
there's some cops in here right so he
goes out of not the exit but he slides
out the way the buses come in that's the
way he went out which was not open to
the public
and the cops were back there he went out
where the buses come in then he went to
the grocery store in san jose
they could tell the future so so he sees
it you see this picture on there goes
the liquor store this lady says what no
well she didn't see him he recognized
himself she didn't see him not until he
got on the bus was he recognized on the
bus
then he started his running track and
that full man ran for me still he ran
across the freeway
ran into east lost he was id he was id
at olympic and soto on the bus yeah
he got off at lorena and soto oh [ __ ]
right right there by yeah right there
where i used to be
you probably ran that every morning when
you're ready to get for the olympics
right yeah
and then he ran through all the houses
and over the five freeway yeah right
there where uh where [ __ ] will i am
used to live oh no [ __ ] that's a real
live in the uh projects right there damn
amazing so that is crawl so they beat
that [ __ ] out of him and then he tried
to uh he was pretty he was pretty run
down though he was run down they gave
him a koscaron with a with a pipe right
the pipe well that was my chef oh is
that right yeah who gave him the hook
and throw it with the putty with a pipe
he went over and pulled out the thing
for the fence
well you know the bad people all have
guns and everything the good people have
pipes people tired yeah a piece of wood
a baseball bat
and
what about the what about you mentioned
the oscar a little knife
the hood rats were still asleep no not
the hood the hood rats because the hood
rats
are are the little uh cholas that i used
to mess with these are the cholos they
got the guys the gang members from the
body okay they're they're still in bed
it's too early for them
they didn't uh they didn't get them at
all or unless you're just getting in for
a [ __ ] baby though
exactly
if they would have been there if they
had been there they'd have killed them
hey you're already married but did you
ever go to baby dose yeah
you couldn't go in there and not get
laid hey i had to go in the room they
would say did you get laid not that i
struck out hey bring one over here wait
a minute
it was so dark in case my wife's
listening i went there on official
business i was a cop remember that used
to be our area before they
annexed it over to monterey park i wish
i was a cop i would be like roberto like
uh the bad lieutenant i'll just walk in
another badge can i talk to you for a
second
what and your wife too
go in the corner and lay down put your
nose in the corner and you come out turn
around three times let me see
oh that's [ __ ] fine i would already
scratch my number out you know how every
badge had a number there when i really
scratched it
i would have took oscar's knife by the
way
scratching remember yeah
make the eight of three
baby doze was the place um yeah so so
ouster de la hoya now you know
wait how do we start talking about
richard we already started talking about
it oh
just because of him right yeah yeah but
you know
do you think well this is there's
another one so richard ramirez was evil
no question about evil but after he got
caught
he he became quiet right yeah and how
come because they were reborn because he
no no no he didn't talk to anybody you
know he got talking he had gotten cut he
got caught he knew he was going to get
caught he was tired of running and then
we established some kind of rapport
because i spoke to lingo i spoke with
the vernacular
and uh
so it was it was all right you know and
you know yeah they made a big deal out
of it when we went to court
uh
we went to court one day he walked in he
looked at me sorry carrillo
and
the reporters went nuts and the only one
that understood what he said was tony
bellew from channel load
and he stood back and he laughed and he
came and did an interview with they were
wondering hey was that a death threat
what was he saying and because we got
along fine okay so
you said that you said that rich ramirez
had like chemistry like he had magnetism
that women when they saw him
they they they wanted yeah they're women
to follow them love them didn't they
marry him or something one of them got
married
good [ __ ] crazy
dude she had to be a [ __ ] hood rat
she was an ugly hood rat okay so if if
if richard ramirez could pull women
what do you think oscar could pull oh
dude
perpetually handsome
yeah yeah i'm ready to throw everything
dude yeah
all right
hey tell me tell me the story you told
me on the talk show with that lady
through her underwear
and when they got in the air they got
bigger and it was like it was like a
[ __ ] parachute
i'm [ __ ] i i
i'm fighting in el paso right at the sun
bowl [ __ ] 80 000 people let me say
this hey richard was probably there
let me say this in my talk show in the
two years
there was a lot of surprises
him coming out
and doing what would be comedy for 20
minutes and they went crazy i mean i
don't think i was
more surprised by how funny a person
could be
than oscar telling the story i got good
stories
so so he's fighting that i remember that
fight too outside of the sun bowl
um
so el paso was just [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] just going crazy you know and
and so 80 000 women are at the at the
sun bowl right and so
um i land the week of the fight it's
like wednesday you know you have a press
conference and the way and then the
fight saturday so we land boom and then
we see all these people there behind the
fence
they're like waiting for me [ __ ] just
yelling oh oscar yeah
and so my pr people are like dude don't
even [ __ ] run across the tarmac and
don't even go to those people and what
do i do i [ __ ] run across the tarmac
and you know yeah so i'm signing
autographs started out we're having fun
you know curiosity are you latino
so we're having fun signing autographs
you know and then you know they throw
they throw hats sign my hat they start
throwing shirts you know sign my shirt
i'm you know whatever i was saying
whatever
and uh all of a sudden they start
throwing bras so we're like [ __ ]
[ __ ] hey dude i haven't seen a
[ __ ] bra in like two months from
training yeah
probably [ __ ] busted or not right
there but
but there goes his legs
[Laughter]
my left leg was like
[ __ ] and then so the bra start flying
over you know 35 36 d whatever
it's not normal they're just clocking it
but they're pretty impossible
and then so all of a sudden all of a
sudden from the back
boom
and everything turned like slow motion
and this [ __ ] parachute
i thought it was a pair of [ __ ] the
[ __ ] the fan man was coming down
and [ __ ] this thing and everybody
just goes oh [ __ ] and it falls on the
ground
oh you know what like you know like when
the [ __ ] like like a little kleenex
falls
on the ground
and we're laughing what the [ __ ] and so
buddy gets it with a pencil and he's
like who's his ears
and god bless her so she was she must
have been like 500 pounds she goes
it's mine and they're [ __ ] just
flapping
everybody's like their hair is [ __ ]
going back
it's [ __ ] it was a proud baby
it was the funniest thing about that
that was a good time that was a good
time and uh uh um
how do you feel you look you look
amazing i feel good bro i feel [ __ ] i
feel good i've been training for six
months man wow i find it hard to believe
to look at him right now that he's
getting ready to get in the bra i feel
that you have all this background now
you're gonna
you look good you know you know what i
what i s what i really feel um because
tyson was my inspiration
when i watched him fight against um uh
uh roy jones jr how do you think he
looked though i mean i mean when he was
like
he looked before he looked great for 50
no no what is he
56 i thought he looked good i thought he
looked good
against roy jones jr who who who boxes
right so tyson if he had him in front he
would have knocked him out right okay
what i'm saying so that that's what
makes you kind of look slower and bad
when you have to chase him you know
right okay um
i thought he looked good and then right
away i said you know what i'm gonna
[ __ ] do this man i'm gonna do this
before i get older
you know so here i am man i feel [ __ ]
amazing man i feel amazing and i'm not
i'm not i'm not
saying that i feel
the same
when i was in my prime
i [ __ ] you not i feel better
really wow yeah that's amazing because i
mean
the one thing that people
don't really understand about
oscar de la hoya's credentials as a
fighter
is
how many how many titles have you won 10
10 in six weight divisions yeah i mean
maybe who else has done that uh
pacquiao's pacquiao's the only one to
have more yeah pacquiao i mean yeah and
he was you know
i don't know
i don't know he drank some of the
he drank some of your beer
he drank he might have been the tester
because before he fought he was told
like a kleenex right there
but
i mean boxing is
you know it's just such a
it's such a beautiful i mean if you
think about like i wasn't
famous when oscar
was
in his prime but i would be in vegas at
the particular times i quartey
it was i was in town i quartet at harris
and i think somebody knew him we called
him
but the excitement of of a boxing match
and a boxer that could make las vegas
stand up and take attention
was was oscar i mean that that command
of of
women and of men and of celebrities and
of the whole world of boxing coming to
vegas
for that to see oscar fight that's
pretty cool it was um
you mentioned i cortez
literally the only guy i mean the guy to
hit the hardest i've ever been hit
harder than my [ __ ] mom even [ __ ]
spank me with
yeah crazy
crazy um yeah from africa from ghana
um when you when you when you sign up to
fight a guy like that since you probably
haven't been hit by them yeah do they
tell you this guy hits hard sure you
watch my video i knew and you know that
somebody hits hard well well the one
thing that i pride myself
i always have is that i always fought
the best i always fought the toughest i
always fought them in their prime i
always thought you know that was my it's
like mikey you know hey give it to mikey
he'll eat it sure i was like
i was like that um with with all
fighters you know so
when they told me hey there's this guy i
corte there's a choice of three guys i
corte
uh you know two other guys i got a
[ __ ] quartet let's go you know so so
i knew right there and then that yeah
this is gonna be [ __ ] tough
tough right and it sure was man 12
rounds of hell
[ __ ] 12 rounds of well-rounded he
dropped me twice i dropped him three
times
i almost had him out in the 12th round
but it was like a rocky movie
i hit him with like 20 punches still
standing up he was like this
[ __ ] throwing referee won't referee
won't stop the fight referee won't stop
the fight back then they didn't stop
fights like you know now it's like then
they can sneeze on you and they stop
them right you know
and uh yeah it was a brutal fight man
brutal fight but i loved it do do the
do the referees stop well back then
they let you fight
and then they would criticize they would
criticize referees for saying that yeah
they let a guy yeah they they let him
too long like you know what the [ __ ]
it's a fight it's a fight what about uh
what about um meldrick taylor and chavez
yeah well that was way too long that
that actually it wasn't because taylor
was you remember that fight yeah no
meldrick taylor was beating chavez
melder taylor was an olympian yeah gold
medalist it's a great fight oh it's one
of the best fights in the history and
he's fighting julius caesar
taylor was
beating up chavez the whole fight
and the last round chavez got this
energy that just i mean that's that that
was chalice if you haven't seen it oh my
god you can watch it from the first
round yeah so the last and it it's
exciting until the end make sure you
watch it with associate and that yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it was bad it was a good fight well
pick it up on youtube yeah big time
there's some there were some great
fights i mean in that era of when he was
fighting with us was fighting was
fighting no mma no
no no no no side hustles yeah just
boxing
and and and what's crazy after that
fight the referee committed suicide
really i don't know for what reason
but they found them in this hotel
room yeah wow that night oh wow right
after all right after whoa
crazy [ __ ]
was that a part of boxing like mobsters
back then
in my time now i don't think so i mean
you had don king right who's not around
anymore i mean he is but he's not
promoting but
i think that was the last of like the
the
you know the the crooked
you know dark side of boxing you know
yeah now you don't you don't really
i mean me being a promoter i've never
been approached by anybody or i've never
told any judges yeah you know you know
what's up right you know what i'm saying
it's never happened it's never happened
but
yeah this sport this sport is pretty
crazy when you started to get back into
training you said you've been training
for six months um
how did you i mean the one thing about
you is i can see you and you can look
one way and i see you again and you look
another way
but then i see you this way and you look
like you used to look when i used to go
see the fights yeah i mean you look like
you oh it's crazy man it's like i i i
feel like turned back the clock
you know all the [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] [ __ ] it's just like the
last ounce of [ __ ] is just out of my
system right yeah just that took me six
months so forward to it coming coming up
now you know less training you only got
two weeks oh yeah now right now it's
like i have this week
it's like my last hard [ __ ] week of
just like you know and then the week of
the fight it's just relax just chill
so that's when you build up that's when
you build up like the week of the fight
like i can't be around you guys i can't
i [ __ ] can't this guy oh this guy
is gonna get his ass kicked if he's like
10 feet close to me yeah nine feet he's
[ __ ] so so it is so it is that you do
become like getting it covered like that
yeah
he'll hit it it'll leave
but it but you do get to where your
almost like a caged animal you're just
ready ready to go yeah and what's crazy
is i miss that feeling man
i can imagine [ __ ]
man when i first when i first went to
the gym the first day six months ago
[ __ ]
i couldn't i couldn't the next day i
couldn't even get out of bed man it was
crazy it was like like what the [ __ ] am
i doing and you know i have to say that
that with all the [ __ ] that happens
in life and with the kids grow up and
yeah and everything and then you have
your
you know your your
time when you were i mean
if not in a short list of the greatest
fighters of all time and then to go back
and be able to go back and do it again
for you like exactly like you know guys
run alongside you in the morning or they
do whatever but
when you get in there it's only you when
you were a kid and you were starting and
you had you know nerves about fighting
and just with the gear and all that it's
still just it's still just you so to go
back and know that
now you say you feel like you did when
you're in your prime right that piece
that wherever it goes right it came back
right yeah and now you got it you know
what's crazy is um like people ask me
like why are you doing it like what
what's what's going on like why you know
you don't have to i mean [ __ ]
i'm i'm actually doing it for myself
you know as well because i've yeah and
you hit it right on the head because
everything that i've been doing is for
everybody i you know i perform for the
world you know
and when i got my ass kicked from manny
pacquiao 13 years ago
right
i retired
i retired because i got my ass kicked
i didn't retire because i wanted to
retire you know
so
i'm i'm in front of the staples center
and there's [ __ ] thousands of media
and i'm saying and i'm crying
reading a speech that somebody wrote for
me
um
it's my last fight
but in my head i'm like this is not what
i want this is not the way i want to go
out you know
and so
it actually took me 13 years
to have the balls
and come back and say you know what i
want to go out my way
you know you know what i'm saying well i
was at the fight i was at the pacquiao
fight and i was at your retirement the
retirement was sad
yeah the retirement out there it was sad
because dude you know here's a guy that
for us in the community is he's our hero
sure and
to see him say goodbye
and still look
yeah it was fresh bro i was you're just
like i never got into wars you know and
i never got into like wars where it was
[ __ ] and stuff a lot of people were
crying we're all crying in there that's
why nobody cried at my retirement i was
looking the way i do right now yeah
you know
yeah you had your badge covered you
couldn't get everybody
but but and then and in that time um
and in that time i would i would assume
that you probably think of it every day
oh [ __ ] when you love it you think about
it every people people ask me like uh
you know
like do you miss it every [ __ ] day of
my life
every time i wake up i miss it i wish i
can do it i wish i can go running i wish
i can
you know get punched punch somebody yeah
you know it's crazy you know i sit here
in awe because i can see the realities i
hear what you're saying and i can see it
i can feel it
and i just sit here in all of you yeah
it's no it's it's been thank you for
everything you've done
for the fight fans what you've done for
the fight business and what you're about
to do yeah what's crazy is uh
like like i was saying i i did it for
everybody i did all these years like
it's for everybody the gold medal for my
mom the world titles for the fans for
the people for my dad
you know what i actually want to do this
for me now you know
yeah
okay i hope you don't mind me me uh
saying this i didn't know i didn't know
your mom but i know how much you loved
her
i know how difficult it must have been
with all of with that at a time when you
were just starting you were going to the
olympics and everything
but
your dad your dad's a pretty tough dude
um yeah like emotionally hard you know
just hard uh
yeah emotionally like you know it's like
till this day you you you i still wait
for like hey i'm proud of you son uh i
have a good story dude all right funny
story uh
by the time you finish the story he'll
be he'll be crying
so so you know i mean i went to the
olympics you know won the gold medal
tara
and still you get no validation you know
like
hey son i'm proud of you dude hey i love
you dude what would he say in those
times man he wouldn't
i mean it's hard hey you
you could have done better
you know you know what i'm saying you
could you could have uh you know hey
all right hey pretty good but come on
you can do better
and so
it's crazy right
so just just just just last year
i said you know what [ __ ] it i'm gonna
do it i'm gonna tell him i love him you
know i'm gonna [ __ ] go up to him and
tell him i love him
so you know it's like we're at a party
with my tia's house you know whatever
everybody's drinking you know how can i
i gotta get in the slot you know i gotta
have about three four beers just to get
a slush
you know just you want to be like point
that's awesome
0.10.12 is a little too much but 0.10
you're in the slot
it's too much so
so i go to my dad hey hey
i love you and i [ __ ] go like tyler
you know like like if he's gonna hit me
or something you know like he's gonna
react like in a weird way
and he [ __ ] gets me and tells me i
love you too sonny starts crying how
crazy is that i never expected that
never expected that that happened last
year
and if you wouldn't have reached out to
him no he doesn't know how to do it in
the slot he doesn't know how he just
doesn't know how you know and as
a as a young father too like he was his
life hard with his parents work hard on
him they were hard on the only the only
story i literally know about him the
only speech he wouldn't say anything no
he wouldn't tell you oh never no story
we don't know [ __ ] about him the only
story he told us was that our
grandfather
tied him to a tree in mexico right
because he was a herder of of cows of of
you know when he was like 12 years old
he didn't want to do it like at 12
midnight he was scared to go up the
mountains or whatever so they his his
father tied him to a tree in chains and
started whipping him that's the only
story i know about him wow crazy oh my
god yeah isn't that crazy
like oh [ __ ] yeah hey how was your dad
oh yeah yeah he got whipped a lot you
know
that's all i know and in those times
that i would see your dad
uh
i'd go and say hello but you could feel
that this dude was yeah it was really
very close you could feel the wall you
know you could feel that wall and he's a
nice guy nice guy but just closed you
know just you know as you were telling
the story and george said this guy
thought they'll be crying before you're
done with your story
because my dad never said i love you
right yeah the night before he's
he dies
he's in the hospital and i told
everybody to clear the room
i wanted to talk to my dad and i went up
to my dad and i had never told my dad i
loved you yeah
so i went up to him and i said
dad and i grabbed his hand i said i just
got to tell you something i said i love
you
and my dad looked at me and said
me too
he didn't say i love your words yeah
yeah yeah he said me too that was just
the way it was yeah and all i ever
wanted to do just wanna hear him was
make make him proud of me i want him
right right and and and i loved him and
i know he loved me i mean it wasn't
it was a good relationship
i learned the next morning how much
it meant to him
they found all the ten thousand dollars
cash deed to the house all the important
papers and it was wrapped up in an
article about me
where i would when i had been in vietnam
trying to help start an orphanage back
okay
and so it wasn't until a year later
when his my dad had already been dead
he had already passed away his boss
called up said hey
send your son down to pick up uh my
kentonovich supervisor was his dad
pick up christmas gift for your pop
i went down here and his old friends
were in there he said your careers boy i
said yeah oh i'm blinky i'm lean no i'm
negro and you know
i said i've heard all about you i've
never had a pleasure meeting you and he
says oh your dad was so proud of you
from the time you went into the army
then when you became a cop will be
[Laughter]
you like easy money who doesn't like
easy money head to my boogie dot ag bet
the nfl lock of the season and when your
team scores between the dallas cowboys
and the tampa bay bucks you win
the best bet you can make is one you
can't lose
and in case you didn't know a game
hasn't ended 0-0 since world war ii so
this is a sure bet that's awesome it
really is that's that simple
join my bookie now bet the lock of the
season and when the first point is
scored in the season opener on thursday
night you automatically cash you know
what i'm going to do i'm going to join
my bookie all right and let's see how i
do this season i'm not a gambler but i
like football and i think this would be
a fun way and thank you my bookie for
allowing people to get a little uh bonus
in their little discount and
it'll be awesome man let's see how we do
head to mybookie.ag today and use your
promo code omghi
that's oh my god hi and instantly
received double your first deposit
that's double your funds to double your
winnings again that's promo code omghi
that's oh my god hi
to receive double your first deposit and
get started with my bookie today bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
you know watching sports is fun but
betting on a team that's not your team
and winning money is better it's
it's the best i started one called
myloogy.com
[Music]
to be world known and to to be a boxer
to
to be an olympian gold medalist a golden
boy
um
even through all that
and he was at all the fights yeah yeah
he never even had the i mean how closed
off is someone when
you're fighting in the highest level and
you win a championship and you're around
your son and you still
not even break character and just be
like can i talk to you and just hug you
or start crying or you see it in them or
anything
i mean it's just it's just you know the
way i see it it's different times you
know the way they grew up you know
like you sometimes have to like
you have to sometimes like feel bad for
them
you know
yeah
it's it's like there are kids now you're
like it's like oh [ __ ] like you you have
to do the work you have to
confront him with you know you have to
[ __ ] make the effort you know it's
it's not fair but
you know once you do it it's like then
maybe they can break down you know but
it's it's not easy you know my three
adult kids now there was not a day where
i didn't go by yeah yeah say i love you
same here bro i did not want them to go
through the same here i got six i beat
you but
you know he does i didn't have anybody
i didn't have anybody throwing
parachutes at me
i had there's all my six kids man tell
them all the time every day i love you i
love you i love you i love you for that
reason yeah it's pretty crazy very
different and you know i've seen those
kids grow up yeah yeah i mean pretty
amazing huh they're great kids man great
kids we played that time i think maybe
2005. how old was what's his name jacob
jacob it was maybe seven bro he's he's
23 now six two and i saw him at a time
i
are you are you mine i saw him at a at
the golf tournament and he goes hey this
is uh jacob and i have a picture of me
an oscar with him and he might have been
seven years old to his waist yeah
dude now he's now now i look up i look
and i'm like oh [ __ ]
flies how are their lives man they are
they good i mean
yeah they're normal man um yeah they're
normal they they you know it's i was
very fortunate um
so i have six kids with four moms right
and their moms were great they they you
know i got lucky i i i got lucky i don't
know something like somebody's looking
out for me you know it's that feeling of
like my mother looking out for me you
know it you know
that's a crazy story in itself but um um
have you seen your mom has she come to
you
in the night and things that you think
about are you in dreams well
they check this one out they do come
check the oh check this out bro okay
so i used to about
i would say
i would say i would say about a year ago
um
it's been a year now but about a year
ago
my life when she passed
my life was a freaking hell dude like
you know
every time if i would drink or whatever
like i would just bawl and cry and you
know like like she was with me all the
time and i would think about her and it
it just pained me you know
so check this one out so
this one girl that i meet third uh you
know that she threw me a little
parachute
[Laughter]
hey i could imagine the oscars
[ __ ] god
on d-day
she went to like india and [ __ ] she
studied like to be a shaman right
to be a shaman
and so we were like very close friends
started on
she goes you know i
one day she's at my place and we're
talking she was actually my interior
decorator for one of my places and i
believe in all this by the way
oh yeah
so so
so she tells me you know what you look
like you look like you're in pain
like what do you mean you know i'm
[ __ ] out just waking up at 12 in the
afternoon
pain can you grab me a beer
and uh
hey
if oscar tells you he's 10 minutes away
he'll be there at 9 30 tonight
that's why today i was like he's on time
i just want to clarify one thing just
just for myself and the thousands of
other latinos are going to hear this
what is a shaman
oh
yeah so so
so she could
so she go she she goes to to india
and she's there for like a year and i
guess it's it's kind of like you're
you're you're a healer like a teacher
yeah yeah oh okay
of natural medicine spirituality and
medicine and almost like vibes you know
let it be known to the to the listeners
even oscar said looked at you and said
okay what are you doing
it's all those ladies that used to live
in the back house with the wells and the
red string and harder to find
like that but but trained in india hey
my thea was a shaman then yeah
yeah so so
so um she goes you know what i i have
something for you that i can i can help
you can i help you out and you know she
was [ __ ] hot
i go yeah you can help me out
so
she has to prepare right so she goes
okay we're going to do it next week
so she goes where do you want to do it
like where do you want to do the
ceremony third i go well here you know
my home i feel comfortable you know i'm
here alone third uh
so anyways one night she gets there she
sets up candles in the room
and uh she tells me why you got to wear
a robe you know to be free you know the
air and all that [ __ ] and you know and
just
you know
and so you're okay
you'll be free man
so she gives me she gives me she gives
me mushrooms okay she gives me mushrooms
i'm like what like what the [ __ ] like
dried up [ __ ] great choro mushrooms
you know
and i'm like what is this like you know
this is this is micro dosing all right
this is i'm like because i don't know
this [ __ ] she's this is micro dosing
just take them so i [ __ ] take them
obviously
and we're talking she asked me about she
asked me about my childhood she asked me
about my mom she asked me about like
just my pain of my past right
i tell her everything you know
and so 30 minutes later we go into the
room there's candles everywhere you know
it's it's a red room it kind of looks
like a strip club
but you know little candles and
everything you know
and uh
so we sit down we're like an indian
indian sitting down like you know indian
style whatever
and she tells me close your eyes and
instantly [ __ ] instantly
i shot up to the [ __ ] galaxy
and now i'm and i don't know what i am
i'm i'm like i'm like air i'm i'm water
i'm this matter i don't know what the
[ __ ] i am but i'm not it's not me right
and i'm looking at the galaxy bro and
there's stars and there's the moon and
the every it was crazy
and she tells me okay and she's holding
my hand she tells me think about
take take yourself to your mom
and all of a sudden i shoot down to the
ocean right i shoot down to the ocean it
was like this thing just shotting down
to the ocean
and i'm going going down thousands of
feet and all of a sudden i stop and it's
beautiful it's [ __ ] beautiful right
and in the back way back over there
maybe 100 feet away there's like this
algae right
and i see something behind it it's like
it's like a thing like it's not it's
it's not it's i don't feel it's like
a fish or whatever it's just a thing you
know
and all of a sudden i feel i feel
that thing just like kind of bows down
right
and right there in that moment i felt
that that was my mother forgiving me
she was forgiving me bro and i felt it
and i felt it man and then all of a
sudden i shot up
and so right there and then
right there and then i felt free from
the pain
um of my mother like i was free i would
i felt it right there and then man and
what's crazy i shot back up to the
galaxy
and i'm
seeing stars and you know all this
beautiful it's just beautiful and she
tells me okay let's go to little oscar
when you were seven years old and i have
had a lot of [ __ ] happen to me you know
when i was a kid you know from being
uh molested from being you know um
[ __ ] uh uh raped at 13 years old from
an older woman you know i've had a lot
of [ __ ] happen to me so
i right away start panicking i have my
eyes closed keep in mind i have my eyes
closed and i tell her i can't do this i
can't do this and she's holding me and
she's holding me i can't do this it's
too [ __ ] painful
she tells me picture little oscar
a hundred feet away from you and there's
a bridge between you guys okay picture
him coming closer to you and i'm saying
i can't do this i [ __ ] can't do this
i'm feeling uncomfortable
and all of a sudden little oscar's right
here
and i [ __ ] wake up like i couldn't i
couldn't i couldn't deal with it i
couldn't deal with it man
so i still have i still have my demons
from my childhood that i have to deal
with
um but i'm free from my mother's pain
right which is great since that time
i've never
now i just love now i just i don't cry i
don't [ __ ] i i just feel love i like
like she forgave me
i always thought that i had to forgive
her you know
i was the bad kid i was the one you know
why did i get hit every day
you know right why did i [ __ ] get
spanked and this and that every [ __ ]
day
it wasn't my fault it was her fault it
was her fault that she felt pain when
she was a kid right her mom beat the
[ __ ] out of you know what i'm saying so
i was free bro and um
now i have to
look for that shaman again i haven't i
don't know where she's at
to free myself from little oscar
it's crazy you know there might be a
chance that that lady
wasn't just really kind of nice i don't
know where she's at
i don't know where she's at you know
it's been a year there's no doubt there
there's no doubt in my mind again oh is
that our timeline i'm i'm witnessing
you know
those spiritually man those things live
like you you gotta make some more but we
can't i'm going to say that
those things live in this world man and
you know
you look at the
thousands of years of people
and you look at
what came before us
and
and the bodies are just bodies but the
spirit is the lightness believe in that
right
i've had things happen to me that are
just you know it's just out in my mind
it's crazy
listening to it but more so unless
you're watching it that was very very
true
uh you believed in it you know you know
who really happened but he didn't
believe in it before no no no not funny
no so that's why you know i think oscar
man and i you know i can tell oscar's
had a lot of a lot of pain
in his life and and i know that that's
why i've asked those questions and and
he doesn't deserve it yeah and you don't
and nobody deserves to to live with it
no it's [ __ ] so he took you know the
one from your mother is great yeah the
mother and little oscar at the same time
was too much oh it was it was
overwhelming but it's too much for a
person at one time i wonder as big as i
am if i'd have to eat more mushrooms to
get me to get off the ground like that
i'm telling you you'd find you'd find
your father
again bro
it's crazy oh yeah it's crazy i i'm a
firm believer in the in the micro dosing
now like i'm a firm believer but souls
and love and yeah people leave but they
don't really leave they leave in their
body but they don't live in their spirit
it's crazy
i'm a firm believer now it's crazy had
you done anything like that before
anyway no no nothing man did you ever do
the handwriting at alberta street
with the lady pixie right
she would write this is a symbol of my
handwriting that she would look at you
yeah and she would and she would tell
you she would just write it out problems
the long fingernail the pinkie
you know
it's funny because you know mine are off
now because no one's it's not me who
what is that nobody oscar goes to that
time
is
nobody uh is the same
social media what i think about social
media is it makes everybody look like
they're having a great life they're not
oh [ __ ] yeah and
people
and kids now you know i sound like i'm
old but they don't work as hard
as the generations that had to come
before them because nothing was given to
them right you know in pain mayans ran
or paying minus car insurance my
grandmother would have never paid my car
insurance my grandfather would have
never [ __ ] helped me pay rent he had
done nothing for me and
i would have had have expected him to do
anything for me and now we almost expect
the kids almost expect you to kind of
float them
and to be there for them and if you're
not somehow they're mad at you i think
mine is mad at me because
when anna nabarro was in town i didn't
call her and tell her that
you know but i told her what days she
didn't call me to check in and i went
and did what i had to do and she was
here and we went to dinner and she's
upset because i didn't call her to
remind her but at some point you have to
remind yourself sure yeah you know and
and i asked myself a lot like uh like
okay whose fault is that like because i
i give my kids everything they [ __ ]
want yeah
because my family didn't
have the means or you know just it was
just different you know
but you're right it's like my kids have
all they have cars they have insurance
they have hey dad can i have some money
for some golf you know [ __ ] tee times
and this yeah sure you know i i i when
the [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah
hey
and and so it's like i sometimes think
to myself [ __ ] well if i don't do it if
i don't give it to them then maybe they
won't be so [ __ ] spoiled you know you
know what i'm saying right so it's it's
it's for me for me it's like is it my
fault or is it or how am i
is anybody even if there's anybody i
blame yeah but do they do they meet you
halfway i don't think so no they just
ask they're just used to it they do
nothing they don't do anything for you
used to it i have my boy that's uh 15 he
wants to be a fighter
but he doesn't want to train
oh no okay i can watch it on youtube and
i'll learn
are you kidding me you got to [ __ ]
get hit yeah you got to get knocked out
to feel it you know no no no no i i can
do it i can do it harder than this guy
so so when you started going to the gym
what because you know some then anna
asked me like why did you keep going
back to do stand-up when you weren't any
good at it and i would cry and one time
i cried in the car and i was like [ __ ]
it i don't need this [ __ ] and the next
morning i woke up and i
went at it again yeah what made you go
back to the gym in those times when
well in in the beginning
i was forced into it i mean i was six
years old so i was just you didn't want
to not [ __ ] no i mean yeah what kid
wants to get hit you know
and and today man but you know what's
funny after when i was nine years old i
was fighting an amateur like fight right
where you get a little trophy you know
and back then they only had first and
second
not [ __ ] seventh place and [ __ ] you
know
[ __ ] seventh participation the trophy
is about to lane halfway up
ten
you know
just like yeah
you know what i'm saying
um so one day i i fought and you know
the uncles are there and because all my
uncles were fighters and my father you
know so we're a family of fighters
so i won
and i get off the ring and my my one of
my uncles gives me like 50 cents
like 50 cents i'm like oh [ __ ]
you know again now and later i'm already
thinking how i'm spending it you know
power leaders you can you know all that
first person later
in your [ __ ] weight loss for like
three years little [ __ ] pig's feet
[ __ ] little pigs
so right there and then i thought to
myself i can i can i can do something
with this you know if i'm if i'm getting
50 cents now maybe you know
and that's how i started loving it what
was the journey to the olympics where
did you have to how did you how did you
get picked or how did you
qualify or where did they see you to say
hey i think you can become you know an
olympian they they actually
there there's actually they there's
actually
a olympic committee
i think when you're like 13 they start
scouting you okay yeah
they're like they're like these they're
like these [ __ ] like people you don't
see you know
you're just training third eye you start
winning tournaments um the the golden
gloves oh yeah so then they start
hearing about you and then the olympic
committee starts sending people like to
the gyms and scouting and this and that
so they have an eye on you so like 13 i
started getting like you know
i guess seen and and you know and and
and categorized as like that's the one
that's the one that's gonna [ __ ] make
it so yeah yeah just winning tournaments
locally
once you start winning locally then you
go regionally and then national once you
went nationally it's like now you're on
their radar you know now they start like
okay that's the guy dude that's the guy
then they they they they assign like
[ __ ] minions you know like okay let's
make sure he doesn't get in trouble make
sure he doesn't you know make sure he
[ __ ] gets aids in school
yeah oh yeah yeah and who did you who
did you fight
what was your way of who did you fight
on the way up to the gold medal
through the gold medal um
did any of those guys ever ever become
fighters beyond the olympians what
remember shane mosley yeah yeah
sugar shane mosley yeah he didn't go to
the olympics but he was like right there
he was right there i think he got beat
by vernon forrest
paul gonzalez
he was a lawyer yeah east la in 1984.
yeah he went to the olympics well he was
he was like one of my heroes i mean you
know growing up we grew up in the same
neighborhood same gym
but i i had crazy that two dudes came
from the same neighborhood same gym and
went to olympics yeah
we he fought uh let's see i fought i
fought check this one out
so i
throughout my amateur career i hadn't
lost in like 10 years
beating everybody's ass
man and we're talking about
we're talking about dude i had 245
fights
yeah so so i'm beating everybody so it's
and we go to australia to fight for the
world titles and it's like kind of like
a pre-olympic you know just to see where
you're at in the world you know wow
so you have to fight five times to win
the gold right five different countries
so i'm i'm i'm the favorite you know i
go in there like [ __ ] okay i'm gonna
win you know i feel confident
my first fight i go up against germany
and he beats my ass
[ __ ] beats my ass i locked himself i
locked myself inside the room for like
at least like six days i didn't come out
i was i was [ __ ] devastated you
hadn't lost him forever for 10 years and
the guy beat you and i was only 16 years
old would you say that he beat you yeah
he kicked my ass he [ __ ] kicked my
ass yeah so then
so then
right after that my mom passed away okay
she passed away she had breast cancer
stage four you know it's crazy i she
passed away i actually retired for like
three four months like i said you know
what that's it i can't i can't my mom's
not here third yeah devastating
and then all of us like like you said
you know you feel them you one day it's
like i woke up i was living in a in a
garage in east l.a with my brother
sleeping in in bunk beds and one day
like at four in the morning i woke up
and i said you know what i have to go
back and train yeah you know it happened
just like that yeah so i re-qualified
for the olympics
made the olympic team 1992
and i had to face so i faced africa the
first fight tough fight second one was
korea boom beat them brazil knocked them
out
um
cuba
knocked them out and then i'm thinking
to myself when the [ __ ] is germany
where in the [ __ ] so i'm fighting in
the gold medal round
and in the [ __ ] corner while going up
the ring there's [ __ ] germany oh man
yeah yeah i mean i was [ __ ] scared as
[ __ ] because i promised my mom i would i
would win the gold medal
so i'm scared as hell
and so
it just i mean it's like you know how
things just happen for a reason you know
it's just it happens you know
like call it karma call it whatever
yeah first round dropped them won the
fight easy actually i won that i mean i
i can't even remember like was it the
same guy with the same guy oh my god
jeremy today marco rudolph
right now
world renowned world known oscar de la
hoya
the guy from germany weiner schnitzel
right there
but i mean
i mean imagine at that age that that he
the water coffee oh it's brewing yeah
yeah we could do it we're almost done i
don't want to keep you longer than that
but but
i mean
to be in that moment that yeah
you're like man this is
crazy
it's life is crazy i remember you're a
young kid i was now now i'm 17.
17. man i'm on top of the podium
i still get [ __ ] choked up on top of
the podium and listening to the
nationals i'm looking at you man and i'm
trying to i remember that and i see you
right on grassroots and
and i'm like this with with my gold
medal with the flowers i give you
and i'm trying to
be happy but i'm [ __ ] devastated and
sad as hell but i couldn't cry i was
just frozen you know i was froze because
you know my mother passed away you
probably felt pretty alone
up there because the minute you win
that's over now you're back to the
reality of
you know
you're up there and then
i mean
yeah i think you would have given
anything for your mom to
oh come on so i so i go down
out of the ring right and then there's
there's there's nbc who's televising the
whole thing and the world's watching i
remember yeah and i think it's fred
rogan
he's still i think he's here in uh still
on nbc uh yes he is yeah and he tells me
uh
so golden boy
how does it feel to do it for your
mother and right there i just [ __ ]
broke down no dude i couldn't even talk
couldn't even talk [ __ ] and crying for
days
yeah it's a great story are you remember
that yeah yeah it was a big story i saw
i remember officer seeing first your
first fight on cbs yeah yeah your first
fight was on youtube remember watching
oscar and you were telling the story you
know he's six years old he didn't want
to fight and who wants to do that i
remember mondo ramos when he was in the
ring he was going through the same thing
he didn't want to fight he was afraid
his dad was pushing him yeah to get in
the ring that's crazy there's a lot of
sad stories man you know bobby chuck on
you know came from san fernando
and i don't know if there's a sadder one
of the we talked about that's fighters
yeah
did he did he even do those
documentaries all right
you think
um so even directed eva longoria
directed some documentaries and she's
like uh you know she's in there and she
you know she actually she actually did
she caught she caught the moments and
she actually um which is coming out soon
um she did the uh
we had her do uh chavez versus de la
hoya
yeah i did it yeah yeah that's right
that's right and you know chavez versus
de la hoya was a big big fight yeah
because well the way it divided cultures
it divided cultures and and think about
when oscar was in his prime
the criticism was that he wasn't from
mexico wasn't mexican so he wasn't
mexican enough but he was born in the
united states
so you can't plan where you're born
right and he took a lot of [ __ ] from
people because they didn't think he was
mexican enough yeah so then here he had
to fight julio cesar chavez which is he
was more mexican king the king king of
mexico
and
he beat the [ __ ] out of him once i beat
him bro it's like once see here here i
am in the olympics right i come back and
my life has changed forever
everybody [ __ ] loves me because you
know my mom's story and they were
playing it big
cancer third eye you know this kid wins
right so i had crossed over you know now
the world is like
enamored you know
but
when i face chavez when we sign the
contract it's like [ __ ]
now now all of mexico is against me even
uncles were like what the [ __ ] are you
doing dude like this you know
and uh huge fight so when i b i remember
when i beat him
i was like oh [ __ ] now i'm the [ __ ]
king you know
and
no [ __ ] no i was like the
enemy public enemy number one man i was
the villain now
i you know how many eggs i got thrown at
me no [ __ ] [ __ ] eggs yeah oh man and
i had my pops there too and i remember
him fighting with the with the cholas
and the trolls hey what the [ __ ] i'm
mexican he's mexican too
because people didn't accept me as like
as as mexican you know you know i'm
saying this it was crazy it was crazy so
what about when he's coming up nobody's
pinching they're never happy you know
they're never happy the 12 marines i got
blamed for the what happened to the 12
marines in afghanistan god bless them
somebody sent me a message saying you
know you're you're
this and that hey thanks
that's crazy man it's it's it's it's
wild out there yeah it is but you know
nothing
yeah obviously not on your way up
nothing and then all of a sudden you
become a pro now you now in in success
you divided the the cultures now yeah
it's it's it's a it's a did you guys
yeah we did and the second time two
years yeah the second time it was it was
yeah it was a fun fight it was a fun
fight because i remember
the first fight everybody was like well
he he started saying no i was you didn't
beat me i was already cut because the
referee stopped it because of a bad cut
i remember hit him with a solid jab and
he was just cut
and it was four rounds and so
everybody started believing oh yeah
chavez wasn't ready
so i said okay
two years later okay let's fight again
then so i wanted to fight him because i
boxed the first fight i was i mean
nobody could stop me that that fight
that night right there nobody can touch
me i was [ __ ] a machine
the second fight i said you know what
i'm gonna stand in front of you and
fight you with balls dude like right
here let's go and sure he almost knocked
me out but
that's the ninth round he didn't come
out cause i hit him with an uppercut
boom
and i busted his teeth through his
through his throat his lip right here so
his teeth were like cooking sticking out
and so he went back to his corner and
and they stopped the fight you know wow
and so right there i think i got a
little more respect but you know but
even then it's like you beat our hero
you know and what about now if you saw
him now it's not we're cool we're cool
everything's cool yeah we're cool what
about his son you know did his son still
fighting his son uh yeah he just got
beat by anderson silva
just got beat back i mean that guy was
top-notch for a second
yeah he was good
you know what it was
like yeah yeah discipline so listen so
as much problems as oscar de la hoya
even talks about what going on in his
head
when julio chavez
after he fought he would go back to
mexico and live in a cocaine tree
for like three months i mean nobody
would have partied harder
than him when he would go back he'd hang
out with the sinaloa cartel oh bro
listen my mom didn't want me to hang out
with a couple of dudes because one wore
a bandana one day i don't want
this dude would hang out with the
sinaloa cartel and you wouldn't see him
he wouldn't go home
and i mean
he
he was out there he went hard he went he
went hard he went hard i remember um
late years later i think they have
cocaine trees where he
in the village
years later
[Laughter]
years years later years later right he's
retired um i think i'm retired too and
he invites me to kuliakan
okay that's where it goes down that's
what the trees so he invites me to
kuliakan because he's having an opening
like ceremony like a cutting ribbon
ceremony
to one of his rehab centers
did you know that he has he has he now
has rehab centers right he's no he's
squeaky clean now yeah which is awesome
which is amazing it really is good
that's good so so so i we land room you
know don king is there like tons of
people you know
and julio gets me you know
and by the way
i land and i'm thinking [ __ ] because
this is the first time i'm in kuliakan
and i'm thinking i'm gonna get [ __ ]
killed here you know i beat chavez no
everybody was a sweetheart everybody was
respectful everybody was beautiful
so then chavez pulls me over and puts me
to the side and tells me hey
this is where i trained this is where i
trained all my life this is my home i
come i wanted to convert it into a rehab
place
because i have so many [ __ ] demons in
here it reminds me of that [ __ ] and he
actually even told me i would sleep here
for with nobody seeing me for three
months at a time just [ __ ] doing blow
left and right dude
oh this guy was [ __ ] yeah he was but
but you you see his life now
and it's it's it's it's it's pretty
pretty badass you know what thank god
because i mean it's beautiful because
you know a guy like that or or
people from mexico or mexicans or
anybody with demons like you think
you're
um
that you can't you can't be good like
you can't go clean you can't change your
life yeah if he if he did anybody can
because he won
that was a tough place i was down there
uh invited back there with some other
guys to go watch a graduation of some
cops from over there that had done some
training out here with us yeah i went
back there and we were allowed uh
they allowed us to go out do whatever we
wanted but at night
we had to stay inside the hotel don't go
out on the streets at night because the
cartel runs the streets oh it has
yeah
crazy yeah i mean if if if he can
anybody can that's for sure no if he can
anybody hey i have a [ __ ] chance you
know now now you know
now you want to talk about like east la
versus like
what a chicano is or what lack of
respect is and then what could
potentially happen to somebody
uh briefly let's talk about when you
fought fernando vargas ah yeah so
fernando vargas was coming up yeah a
little bit of exciting you're already
you're oscar de la hoya i'm established
yeah he's calling you out calling you
upon calling you
he's he's the bad boy you know yeah yeah
yeah he's the bad boy but he's bad ass
you know he's a good fighter [ __ ]
yeah really good
um strong as [ __ ] you know and and he
was from uh he is from oxnard yeah
you know tough neighborhood third eye
this and that
and so all of a sudden we we're gonna
fight
you know and he's in his prime you know
he i think he had just
fought uh trinidad or
something like that um
but we all trained in big bear
right here in southern california
right yeah
and big bear
and it's funny because we would always
cross each other um like his posse and
my posse we would always cross each
other during like morning runs you know
and it was kind of like [ __ ] uh
what's that what's that movie where
they're like [ __ ] with knives and
[ __ ] like you know it's like west sides
and so
and then it was just heated you know
the whole build-up of the fight was just
[ __ ] but what was he saying about you
oh that i know you're getting that yeah
mexican now you're [ __ ] sellout this
and that what all that [ __ ] yeah
and uh so it's fight week right and i'm
hearing rumors that this guy's [ __ ]
he trained like a [ __ ] you know
and i'm like okay whatever i trained too
you know no big deal so it's the
weigh-in you were there
it's the weigh-in right
and we couldn't get close to each other
because [ __ ] was going to go down
so they i remember at the arena they
built a huge long stage i had to be over
here and he had to be over here because
or else if we met we're going to throw
down right there you know and there's no
fight
so i remember being on stage and there's
like thousands of people watching the
the weigh-in and so he he he
gets up on stage takes off his shirt bro
and he [ __ ] looks like a bodybuilder
he starts flexing oh and he's he's
[ __ ] ripped
and i look over to my brother hey [ __ ]
oh yeah this guy's [ __ ] kidding oh
[ __ ]
and i had to think of something how to
deflate his [ __ ] his bubble his his
his balloon you know
i looked at him way across the [ __ ]
the the the stage and then went like
that
like telling him i'm in the [ __ ]
right here
because you can't build the chin you
know you can't build up the chin because
i had a i had a feeling he was on
something you know because he looked he
looked abnormal like a [ __ ] wrestler
yeah
toughest fight i've ever been in he
almost had me out in the first round
through the ropes strong as hell
we were going at it
[Music]
all of a sudden 11th round i knocked him
out knocked him out i
[ __ ] hit him to stop the fight
a week later
uh the anti-doping whatever
they popped them for steroids and it
wasn't for it wasn't [ __ ] just
steroids it was a [ __ ] good [ __ ] yeah
you know yeah the anabolic uh you know
[ __ ] puts you like a burro you know
and
and it's funny because a week after that
and then and the and the victory's
sweeter than ever because now he's on
stage
a week after that because the beef was
so
intense really intense
um i called up one of his
representatives and i said hey let's um
let's let's patch this up man you know
it's like we can do [ __ ] together and
you know and [ __ ] you know and grow
the rasa or you know yeah yeah sure
and so we meet up in pasadena i get
there first to the restaurant you know
and i'm sitting down and it's like we
closed down the restaurant you know it's
like [ __ ] it's like a [ __ ] mobster
yeah yeah
he gets there like [ __ ] half hour
late and [ __ ] and i'm like okay cool so
i he i see him walk in he's with glasses
and i i go to extend my hand to him and
he goes
nah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you didn't beat me
i want the [ __ ] rematch i want the
rematch
and i'm like ah [ __ ]
this guy yeah i'm like [ __ ] you know i
and i just got up and left yeah yeah
just got up and left couldn't you
couldn't really talk sense into him or
you know because it's the heat of the
moment here
the good thing now is that he's a
totally changed
family man [ __ ] his he's training his
kids
nice guy i actually help out his his
charity organization every year you know
we're good friends which is the dude
that you tortured for talking [ __ ]
my yorga yeah
yeah ricardo my orga that was a good one
that was a good one that was a [ __ ]
good this guy's talking [ __ ] about me
life at the time
i made him
i made the fight last longer so i could
kick his yeah
i had him down in the first round
when i knocked him down boom and he's
looking at me like
i go [ __ ] you i'm gonna [ __ ] let you
go about a few more rounds just to make
you suffer i remember floyd mayweather
seniors floyd mayweather senior yeah was
training me for that fight
the first round ended and i'm going back
to my to the corner and floyd gets me
[ __ ] throws me in the corner what the
[ __ ] are you doing you should have
knocked him out in the first round and
i'm thinking i wanna [ __ ] kill him
yeah yeah yeah
the cup man that passed away
uh legend huh oh chuck bodak chuck bodak
the guy that used to wear stickers on
this yeah yeah yes yeah chuck bodak so
he would he would wear like a collage of
like
yeah stickers around his like a crown
around his head you know he was
legendary but he can start he can stop
hugging he can stop a woman from getting
her period
that's awesome he can make you not
believe
[ __ ] amazing man
i met angelo dundee at the
at the weigh-in of pacquiao
and uh yeah yeah good dude yeah really
good dudes trained muhammad ali i mean i
remember that's not who angelo was
trying after muhammad he was
trained
maybe cigarette right he told somebody i
remember he's in the corner and says if
you don't start [ __ ] moving your head
you're going to break his hand
out of them yeah yeah it's crazy man
those are good times though beautiful
times beautiful times it's different now
you know it's different now it's
different now i i don't think i don't
think we get the same fights as we do
like back then you know there's not too
much action these days yeah a because
fighters not that they're good or
they're not good you know no it's just
they're a little more cautious
it's more about the business now you
know
you know what i'm saying is triple g
still fighting uh he hasn't fought since
canelo i think i don't know it's crazy i
haven't i haven't heard from him for a
while yeah
good great fighter great fighter yeah um
you know then the referees too they
stopped the fights too early yeah you
know it's like they see a fighter like
wobble a little and let me stop it yeah
let him recoup at least you know
give him a chance you know so after sub
september 11th um
are you going to fight anymore after
that it depends man it depends how i
feel
if i if i if i feel great if i feel that
i'm on my toes and i get a victory or
you know it just all depends if i do
that if that happens yeah i'm gonna
fight again [ __ ] a you doing are you
following the same kind of treatment or
regimen of training like jumping rope up
and running different it's different
i'm actually training smarter now yeah
actually
angelo dundee
when i when he was training me way back
in the day
i will never forget he had a
conversation with uh sugary robinson
and um
angelo asked some sugar like how do you
how do you uh how do you keep training
at 40 something years old and you're
still you still look incredible you know
he goes uh i just cut everything in half
cut everything in half you know you
train smarter
that's all it is man recovery is big
when you go in there what do you expect
to get from this student he's not a
boxer uh no he actually is oh he is he
almost made the olympic that's and
that's why he chose him because he he's
a ufc heavyweight champion
he's a big guy
and but that's the reason why i chose
him because i want to be challenged you
know
yeah his his first thing is not boxing
but he actually made the olympic team
for brazil almost for boxing okay so he
has skill yeah and this is vitor belfort
right we're talking about the listening
video
so so you know i'm still here in my
[ __ ] old way of thinking man i want
to fight the [ __ ] best i want i want
to be challenged
but i'm expecting a war man let's go i'm
actually i've been
motivated and inspired by hagler hearns
right those three [ __ ] rounds man of
hell great yeah i'm i'm expecting that i
want that you know
just was vegas different when they
fought outside
i i fought i actually was a laughter
yeah i actually was the last one to
fight at outdoor caesar's palace when i
fought chavez that was the last fight
ever remember those ones to fight
outside so when they weren't fighting
the ring stayed up there
and if you passed on the freeway you
could look over to the right and you'd
see it yeah and it looked like
it wasn't the ring's not that big and
the and the stands were stands like you
did you know
at a high school
and it didn't look like much and then
you would look at it and you would think
some of the greatest fighters in the
world have fought in this area right
there
and it doesn't look like much when it's
empty and then when it's full
it's just it's it's a legendary place
it's literally the olympic auditorium
used yeah
did you ever go there yeah i remember i
was uh my daddy used to take me when i
was six years old
that place is the greatest
area
oh yeah yeah
they didn't like the decision they would
oh yeah in the cup and they had a way to
throw the cup so that it stayed in the
air
in the proper way and then when it
landed just like that
it's like a good night uh ruben navarro
fought uh locally
and all the mexican nationals were lo
mali lo mali and all the guys from the
body were ruben ruben and then here
comes the meows yeah the beer and the
fight it was crazy it was i remember i
remember my dad would um he would he
would leave me he would we would get in
he would go and sit down maybe like in
the half section either you know ten
bucks five bucks whatever and he would
leave me like he would see any little
kids like by themselves like lost
instead and he would just leave me there
like oh go play
you know yeah
that's awesome we would just go play you
know you know and then for some strange
reason after the fights we would just
connect again you know it was quite a
place man like you give me your ticket
and they tear it in half they give you
the whole little little little ticket a
little ticket yeah
you know when i drive by there i want to
go in there and go see what's in there
but i don't i don't think it looks
anything i think i think it turned into
a
chinese church
yeah yeah chinese church
but a lot of a lot of great memories
there man i actually won my first world
title there at the illuminator my
grandfather father and my father father
wow oh wow i got i had the opportunity
to ring announce there for cop fights
at the olympics
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i remember
what lapd versus uh
yeah yeah you guys throw down well man
listen man thanks for coming i love you
man you know i love you you know i love
you brother that's why this might be
right here always
hey remember that one time you [ __ ]
gave me a brownie
no it was in lakeside it was a lakeside
bro i was like i i had even asked hey
you got some milk or something like i
didn't know what a brownie was yeah you
just thought it was a brownie and i ate
the [ __ ] whole thing oh
bro i get home
and i [ __ ] turn green bro i don't
remember like two days after that
it was [ __ ] holiday no no it would
take two days for that
green out for a couple days i forgot to
tell you that
[Laughter]
uh honest mistake
i gave cedric half of uh
and i didn't see it for 45 minutes and
he came back and he goes bro i'm off it
goes i'm initiating conversations he's
like oh you're someplace tennis
tell me about that i mean i
get hired i remember i couldn't stop
laughing
somebody would hit a shot i'll be
[ __ ] laughing at you yeah
[ __ ] david
it was hilarious we had some great times
man yeah good golfer too and a great a
better dude and a better friend
i love it man de la hoya honored a
pleasure thank you brother you
appreciate it thanks for coming in
awesome thanks for coming out all right
appreciate it time for some baby
you